I had a challenge for one of my friends
because he because he saw the post that
I put up with the event and he wanted me
to table this for you okay
um and he said will you ask George how
much longer he's going to be completely
wrong about the market
uh so I said to him all right well you
know
yeah well
you know I said to him so anything in
detail that you want me to raise and
they said okay so there's so many things
but I'll simplify so for those of you
that are sort of like newer to my
channel like George gaming you know he
runs a rebel capitalist conference he's
got a couple YouTube channels he talks a
lot about economics he's a real estate
investor he's friends with guys like
Robert Kiyosaki he's a pretty cool dude
right so
um he you know he puts out a lot of his
uh content around money and what's going
on and sort of like
like from the from the perspective of an
unplugged mail sort of looking at the
code in The Matrix you know sort of
thing I think is probably the best way
to describe it would you say yeah
absolutely I mean what you do with uh
the the Dynamics between men and women
uh you know looking at the code in The
Matrix I try to do the exact same thing
with macroeconomics yeah yeah with
Marcus so he okay so he said uh so many
better simplify it's down to two he goes
uh that would probably be best to ask
off the live feed he goes one does he
really believe the U.S economy the
dollar and the housing market Etc are
going to collapse or does he just
promote conspiracy theories for to get
clicks if he actually does believe it
what is the timeline
okay
Where Do We Begin Rich sorry to Courtney
your brother but you know like I love
you guys both and I thought oh no where
do we get a conversation first of all
what I would suggest this guy do before
asking questions is just try watching a
few of my videos I think he has I mean
he's actually a no he hasn't he's
something he has a manager guy now he
actually hasn't the reason I can tell
you he hasn't is because I'm not talking
about the dollar crashing okay in fact
for the last jeez for the last year on
my channel I've been talking about how
the dollar will not crash okay uh and
I've been talking about how most likely
go up especially if we get a global
economic recession and I talk about the
Dynamics and the mechanics behind the
global monetary system which would
prevent the dollar from outright
collapsing now in fact in a video the
other day I argued that even if the
dollar lost Reserve currency status
it may not collapse because so many
dollars outside of the United States are
created in a way where the supply
creates its own demand so I hate to get
too far into the weeds but to answer
your buddy's question uh when a there's
a couple different ways that currency or
a dollar can be created uh it can be
printed by the government where they
actually literally print a green piece
of paper and that would be what I
consider a supply dollar so that dollar
is just Supply it's just an asset on
someone's balance sheet it's not
simultaneously a liability but the
majority of the currency units
especially the dollars because the
dollar is the world Reserve currency and
we have something called the euro dollar
system so the the dollar is uh you know
represents 67 70 percent of global
transactions the way they're settled
so the majority of the dollars are
outside of the United States and they're
created by Banks lending them into
existence so if you need a home loan
Rich you go to the bank you go to I
don't know whatever the local bank is
there let's just say it's Wells Fargo
that's a popular one in the United
States and you take out a loan for five
hundred thousand dollars those dollars
didn't exist prior they just they put
those dollars bam it's in your account
it's now a liability of the bank and you
can take those dollars and spend them
how you please uh buy the house and then
the offsetting asset on the bank's
balance sheet is a loan that has to be
paid back so you're saying that that any
financial institution in the world
that's tied into the U.S or the U.S
Reserve currency can manufacture dollars
like can can a Canadian Bank like CIBC
for example if they wanted to issue me a
half million dollar or sorry half
million US Dollar Loan generate that in
US dollars out of thin air not all banks
but a lot of the banks outside the
United states can and that's what we
call the network of the euro dollar
system so these are banks and this
system started back in the 1950s and it
was a result of Bretton Woods because
back then you know the dollar officially
became the global Reserve currency so in
order to grow your economy at full
capacity you needed enough dollars but
there weren't enough dollars getting
outside of the United States because we
weren't renting a trade deficit we're
running a trade surplus so these Banks
and these corporations outside the US
had a big problem you know how do we
settle in dollars if if we can't get any
outside the United States they started
creating their own quite literally and
so this is a system that has been in
place since the 1950s that operates with
no Bank Reserves and for those of your
audience those members of your audience
you're a little more sophisticated
you'll know that that's just base money
that's the Federal Reserve when they
quote unquote print money that would be
base money that would be Bank Reserves
so nor there's no Bankers or and there's
no green pieces of paper there's no
dollars in the system at all but yet
they create dollars in the form of
Commercial Bank liabilities
so but they but they lend them into
existence so that the key there rich is
the fact that the bank has to lend it
into existence means that those currents
units have been created but a liability
a future liability for those same
currency units plus interest has also
been created because at some time you've
got to pay you've got to get those
dollars back to pay off the loan you see
where if you just have a green pieces of
paper that's just an asset on a balance
sheet that is not a simultaneous
liability so when you think about the
fact that they're 50 60 maybe even more
I would argue there's probably a hundred
trillion dollars
off balance sheet and on balance sheet
globally is that and is that number
tracked anywhere like is that public
information as far as very very
difficult to track because so many of
these euro dollar banks operate in the
shadows so you really don't know what's
on their balance sheet you definitely
don't know what they have off balance
sheet just enter Bank dollars between
one another so when you think about this
you what I like to do on my videos is
think about a global aggregate balance
sheet so an aggregate balance sheet for
the entire world right you think about
okay you got assets on the left you got
liabilities on the right let's just
assume that there's a hundred trillion
dollars cash that's an asset on the
balance sheet but you also since the
majority of that was lent into existence
you've got a hundred trillion dollars of
liabilities meaning future demand for
those dollars so even if you have the
dollar let's say go from Saudi Arabia
because they're using a new currency you
know the brics currency everyone's
talking about that they're
de-dollarizing okay great sorry
well everyone's talking about how the
bric countries are going to create their
own currency they might back it by gold
so they can de-dollarize this is Russian
Russia Iran Saudi Arabia China exactly
okay exactly exactly and it's a very
good argument they're definitely
dolorizing but that doesn't necessarily
mean that the dollar crashes because
even if those dollars leave the balance
sheet of Saudi Arabia they go somewhere
else and the aggregate balance sheet
doesn't change and the only way that the
liability side goes down is if you pay
off those loans which reduces the amount
of currency units that are circulating
chasing goods and services you see so I
I guess though that's kind of a
long-winded answer that explains the
euro dollar system to a certain degree
and the global monetary system but
that's why your viewers if you're
they're expecting the dollar to crash
um now it might go down as an example if
you have an interest rate differential
like let's assume for a moment
that the bank of Japan and the the ECB
increase interest rates or continue to
increase rates where here in the United
States for some reason the FED takes
rates from five percent overnight down
to you know one percent or something so
there's an extreme interest rate
differential yeah you'll likely see the
dollar go down you know right now it's
trading at about 103 on the dxy uh which
is just a dollar against a basket of
other currencies in that scenario you
might see the dollar trade down you know
maybe 90 uh 80 but let's remember that
back in 2011 2012 the dollar was trading
at 70. 70 on the dxy and was anybody it
was everyone talking about the dollar
losing the reserve currency status back
no of course not and it didn't lose the
reserve status even though it went down
to 70. so I think the probability rich
is actually higher that right now let's
say we're at 100 you know right around
103. I think the probability is higher
especially over the next year that we're
definitely facing a global uh a global
economic slowdown I would say maybe even
a global economic recession or
depression I'd say there's a higher
probability that the dollar goes to 130
on the dxy than going down to 70. and
and by the way since we've heard all of
this talk about dedolarization and the
brics currencies and everything that
we've been hearing about in the news
what has the dollar done it's actually
gone up you know we started around 101
now it's at 103. I mean it you think
that the FX markets the guys who trade
they don't understand about this brics
currency they don't understand about
d-dollarization of course they do but
you got to look at how people are
placing their money not just what
they're talking about I mean you say
this all the time on your channel in
regards to women but it's the exact same
thing with the marketplace don't listen
to what they say listen to what they do
and if we're looking at how people
actually trading dollars they're bullish
on the dollar they're not bearish is it
is it the same with other currencies
like the Euro for example can the US
manufactures Euros out of thin air and
and generate loans for the European
currency that's a great question and it
is true so when I say Euro dollars a lot
of people think that that's like has to
do with the euro currency but it
actually doesn't it just implies that
it's within this network of banks that
aren't under really a purview of any
Central Bank and that they operate kind
of I'd say in the shadows because it
sounds like something nefarious but it's
really not but it is true to your point
they can create Euro dollars they can
create Euro Euros they can create Euro
Yen for that matter
interesting okay I really hope you guys
enjoyed that clip if you want to watch
the full length podcast you can find
that over here that clips from if you're
new to the channel make sure you hit
subscribe over here and pin down below
in the top comment you'll find a bunch
of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out